[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
good morning everyone good morning
distinguished
colleagues and graduates greetings to
all of the
all of you joining us from around the
world online
i'm lynn cooley the dean of the graduate
school of arts and sciences
we are celebrating on the grounds of old
campus this morning
please allow me to acknowledge the
indigenous peoples
and nations including mohegan mashem
tuck at pequot
eastern pequot scouticock
golden hill poguet niantic the
quinnipiac and other algonquin speaking
peoples
who have through countless generations
before us
stewarded the lands and waterways of
what is now connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship
that exists between these peoples and
nations
and this land welcome
to the 2021 commencement for the yale
graduate school
of arts and sciences
this year's ceremony cannot be like
previous ones
in the 160 years of yale graduate school
commencement
we are fortunate to be able to gather as
we emerge from a global pandemic
but we can only share our proceedings
remotely with
families friends and colleagues because
of the pandemic
whether you are here in new haven or on
the other side of the world
we join together in honoring the
persistence
resilience and accomplishments of the
class of 2021.
to the families and friends of our
graduates who are watching
we are grateful for the powerful
inspiration
and support that you have provided our
students through the years
to this great day near or far
we are all part of this celebration
i would like to express my deep
admiration and gratitude to the
university leadership
faculty students and staff
who came together as a community to
continue the work of the university
during this difficult year
thank you president salovey provost
strobel
for your leadership keeping us safe and
product
and as productive as possible even while
the world was
upended joining president salve
and provost strobel and the deans of the
graduate school here on stage
are some other remarkable people the
recipients of the graduate mentor awards
they exemplify the range talent and
dedication of our faculty
nominated by the students graduate
mentor awards
recognize professors who are exceptional
in fostering the intellectual
professional and personal development of
our students
in the past year more than ever the
strain of the pandemic
brought into sharp focus that the
essential core
of graduate education is active
mentoring
the time-honored student faculty
partnership
finds its exemplars in these inspired
teachers
please ring your bells i think you have
them
for jennifer robb associate professor
in the history of art who could not be
here today
gary brudevick benjamin stillman
professor of chemistry
and kelly shu professor of finance
okay that's enough
also joining us also joining us today
are the student marshals who processed
onto old campus with us
lucille armantano soon-to-be phd in
psychology
and stephen gowrin ph.d ecology and
evolutionary biology both are past
chairs of the graduate student assembly
lucy and stephen were inspired leaders
of the gsa
and thoughtful partners with me and
others on campus
as we continually seek to improve
graduate education at yale
thank you for your exemplary service
during our time your time in office and
congratulations on your graduation
yeah that's okay
and now i would like to invite president
peter salovey
chris arges professor of psychology to
deliver his remarks to you
president salovey
thank you dean cooley
good morning everyone congratulations to
all of you graduating today and it's a
privilege
for me to be able to share a few words
with you
so graduations are important milestones
no matter
when they take place but your graduation
will always be exceptional for over a
year we
have walked a strange and historic path
together
we're now at the end of an academic year
like no other
but although our traditions may look
different this year
they're just as meaningful as ever
commencement is a time of celebration
it's a chance for you to revel in your
accomplishments
but it's also a time an opportunity
to reflect and say thank you
so many people have been part of your
journey to this moment
and i hope you will find time to tell
them how much they have meant to you
i would also like to say thank you to
you
day after day for more than a year
you've made sacrifices for the greater
good
you've studied conducted research worked
under extraordinary conditions
you helped keep our neighbors on campus
and in new haven safe
it's not always been easy like people
around the world you've experienced loss
grief uncertainty
and yet you have repaid our communities
trust and confidence
in you many times over
now as you look to the future
to your lives beyond yale and hopefully
beyond this moment
i would like to share a personal story
it's a story about my past and my
present but i share it because i
hope it will shed some light on your
future
it's about teachers and the gifts they
give us
so in the early 1970s i was a student
at williamsville high school north
outside of buffalo
new york anybody else from buffalo
here today we're not producing enough
graduate students at yale i can see that
well williamsville high school north was
a pretty typical
large public high school we had a
popular football team and a marching
band that played at the games
perhaps it will surprise you to learn
that i didn't play on the football team
but i did march with the band
and you might wonder how i fit into this
kind of a school well i actually earned
a varsity letter
for the drama club but i was part of
another student organization as well
a poetry club hosted by two beloved
english teachers mr and mrs blaisdell
a group of us would go to their home and
share poems we had written or
come across we drank coffee we talked
about poetry
it was all very grown up especially for
kids like us from buffalo
our teachers were only in their 20s
maybe early 30s
but they were sophisticated adults and
therefore seem much older to us
they care deeply about literature
writing
poetry but most of all
they cared about us their students
in fact i'm not the only student of the
blaisdells on the faculty here at yale
they taught english to chemistry
professor scott miller
about a decade after me
fast forward 46 years
the kids from that poetry club
now have families and careers of their
own
a surprising number of them are now
college or university professors
we've stayed in touch but usually we
only see each other
every few years at best
as a way of coping with the social
isolation of the pandemic we started
meeting over
zoom we shared poems once again
we drank coffee together once again
our former english teachers from
williamsville north now retired
joined us and we found
in the midst of so much grief and
loneliness
a way to connect
what does this mean for you first my
hope for each of you is that you have
made a friend here perhaps a few friends
who will be there for you in 46 years
that's no small thing second i hope you
found great teachers and mentors who
will continue to advise and guide you
for years to come and third
i hope you are leaving yale ready to
become those teachers
and mentors to the next generation
i recently had the privilege of
interviewing the poet
louise glick who won the 2020 nobel
prize for literature
professor glick has taught at yale since
2004.
she told me she thinks of teaching as a
way of
repaying her debts you can't thank your
teachers she said except by performing
as they did
for another generation
not all of you will be educators of
course
but you can all repay your teachers
by sharing your curiosity and love of
learning
with the world you came to yale because
you wanted to ask
questions and search for answers
you have earned master's degrees or phds
and you will take your expertise into
universities laboratories and other
workplaces
throughout the united states and the
world
all of you are leaving here with gifts
from your teachers
what are these gifts from my teachers i
learned how to ask
different questions bigger questions
in high school i was always trying to
figure out what a poem was about
i wanted to unlock the secret meaning
but mr blaisdell would tell me peter
what the poem is about is not always the
most interesting question
he encouraged me to appreciate beauty
and occasionally put aside analysis
he pushed me to use different parts of
my mind and my emotions
teachers throughout my life including my
professors in graduate school here at
yale
in the early 1980s shared with me
their deep and joyful love of learning
they modeled curiosity and resilience
they introduced me to interests that
have made my life richer
and more rewarding
it is now your time to serve as a model
for the next generation of scholars
practitioners and professionals
is how we repay our teachers
over the past year we have learned so
much about ourselves and about
what we are capable of and we've been
reminded
again and again that we must keep
learning there will always be new
challenges to tackle
unexpected problems to solve
we'll have to pivot and adapt
and if we love learning if we are
curious about the world and the people
in it then the task will be so much
easier
and more fulfilling
in the book tuesdays with maury the
sports writer mitch album describes
reconnecting with his former professor
maurice schwartz the elderly maury is
suffering with als
lou gehrig's disease
the book is an extended reflection on
life
and death but it is also about the
relationship
between a student and his teacher
at the end album says have you ever
really had
a teacher one who saw you as a raw
but precious thing a jewel
that with wisdom could be polished
to a proud shine if you are lucky enough
to find your way to such teachers
you will always find your way back
i hope you find your way back back to
your teachers
back to yale i hope you will return to
campus and walk down
chapel street and enjoy the sunshine or
the snow
on old campus on the new humanities
quadrangle
on science hill and i hope you will find
ways of sharing the joy of discovery
with others i hope
you share your curiosity with a world
that needs questions
as much as answers a world that needs
light
and truth more than ever
i usually conclude my addresses on
commencement weekend
with a few words of verse after all i
was in the poetry club at williamsville
north
over the years i've read from rabjanath
tagore
elizabeth alexander billy collins
marie boroff and claudia rankin
but most often i've turned to the words
of john milton from
paradise lost you know
those verses about leaving the garden of
eden
with wandering steps and slow
and making one's way into a world that
is all before you
the moments when those lines move me to
tears
in this challenging year though paradise
certainly does not seem like the right
metaphor
for our beloved campus
but i look ahead with great optimism
and i trust you do too
so perhaps these words of emily
dickinson seem more appropriate at this
moment
hope is a thing with feathers that
perches in the soul
and sings the tune without the words and
never stops
at all my friends
you are ready to face the future
with optimism and determination
you are ready to repay the gifts your
mentors
have given you and share the joy
of discovery with others
you go with our best wishes
and our admiration
students of the graduate school of arts
and sciences congratulations
and good luck
thank you thank you president salovey
for being here with us today and for
your wise words and poetry
uh for the first time ever we've said
that many times this year right
for the first time ever at a graduate
school commencement
we have a keynote speaker the remarkable
professor akiko iwasaki
she is a distinguished science and a key
figure in
covid19 research whose work focuses on
the mechanisms of
immune defense against viruses
among her many accomplishments her lab
developed
a new vaccine strategy called prime and
pull
that can be used to treat those already
infected with a virus
unlike vaccines that are given
preventatively
among her current projects professor
iwasaki is directing
a team investigating the role of immune
response in covid19
long-haulers and discovering that the
effects of the vaccine
are beneficial in alleviating persistent
health issues caused by the virus
if you're not aware of her reputation
of in as a med in medical scientific
and public health research
you may have heard or seen her in the
news as she is regularly tapped by
regular by major news media
to discuss her work and to help the
public understand the latest pandemic
related research
she's received numerous awards and
honors
including election to the national
academy of sciences in 2018
and to the national academy of medicine
in 2019
it is an honor to have her here to talk
with us today
please welcome professor akiko iwasaki
thank you very much dr dean cooley for
the kind introduction
it is my great honor to be standing here
today
to celebrate the accomplishments of all
of you who are graduating
with a degree from yale university today
i want to begin by recognizing and
thanking the numerous people
who supported each of you today so that
you can be here to devote yourselves
into this into the studies of your
masters and phd
so let us thank the someone in your life
whether it be your family
teachers partners friends or neighbors
you have made it the past few years have
not been easy for anyone
you have endured the covet pandemic and
persevered in your studies
some of you have lost your loved ones
and were unable to be with your family
in times of needs many international
students
were unable to return to their homes to
be there for your families
during this difficult time just know how
proud they are of you today
to see you graduating with a degree from
one of the finest institutions in the
country
the pandemic wasn't the only turmoil we
faced
the world has become more polarized in
recent years
and the feeling of us versus them
have become more exaggerated racism
which has always existed in this country
has become more
blatant the murder and the police
brutality against so many black
americans
and the black lives matter movement sent
strong message to the world
that racism will not be tolerated
recent rise in the hate crimes against
asian americans
and pacific islanders has shown light
on the underlying anti-asian racism that
has
also always existed the world seems like
a terrible
place hopelessness descends upon us
yet in the midst of this i also see real
signs
of hope in society people are no longer
remaining silent
we are demanding change we are speaking
up and shining light
on structural racism and sexism
so that people who are kept away from
reaching the heights of
that they're capable of are giving an
equal chance
people have shown true courage power and
generosity to others
today on your graduation i want to
celebrate this human resilience our
ability to bring about
change i want to leave you with three
messages
that have helped me throughout my life
and i hope will help yours
my first message is that it is okay to
ignore the naysayers
often we are given solicited or
unsolicited advice from
those who are in senior position about
the direction
we ought to take they may even have the
best
intentions at heart to try to persuade
us
from taking the wrong step so that we
might regret later
i often have such advice i found them
quite
useful and have benefited from many of
them
however i have also received advice that
if i allowed it
or if i followed it would have ruined my
life
in college i was advised not to pursue
career in science
because i'm just not cut out for it
i'm sure my professor had the best
intention to try to persuade me away
from a lifetime
of failure and misery but i'm glad i did
not take it
of course one can argue this is uh there
is survivorship bias in such an argument
but i often wonder how many other girls
were told the same advice
who followed it or who were crushed by
it
and never made it in their dream
profession
my second message is to reflect
internally
about the purpose of your life it sounds
so cliche
and i'm sorry for that but i believe
this question will guide you in the
right path
i suspect i will get a very different
answer from a physicist
and a theologian i'm instead talking
about
the ground level what gives each one of
you the purpose
and meaning in life as you move forward
with your career
into your respective fields of work let
us consider not just
what you want to do with your life but
how you want to live it
this pandemic has forced me to dig deep
within myself and ask what is the
purpose of me being here on earth
in the year 2021
over the years i have asked the same
question and my answer has evolved to
coalesce
around the idea that the ultimate
purpose of my
existence derives from how much positive
impact i can have
on other people's lives it can be so
small as to bring a smile
for a few seconds all the way to saving
someone's life
so please take some time to reflect into
your own inner self
and ask why you are here and how you
want to impact this world my final
message
is to pay it forward as a yale graduate
you have all been giving a gift of
talent ambition and privilege
to pursue knowledge light and truth
how powerful is that how you use this
gift is entirely up to you
someone in your life has supported you
to get to where you are today
that someone may be your family friends
partner or
teacher in other words while you are
absolutely deserved to be
celebrated today your success was not
achieved alone
we all owe it to that someone to pay it
forward to lift up those around us
so that they too have the opportunity to
achieve something great
the amazing truth is that life is not a
zero-sum game
we can all win together a win is more
meaningful
when it benefits as many people as
possible
let's be kind to one another let's be
generous
being kind and generous does not have to
come at the cost of excellence
you can be all of these things on your
life's journey
remember to lend your hands to lift up
others
in closing i leave you with my greatest
hope
the hope that each of you will walk out
of this place to make this world a
better place for others
that you will give boys to the voiceless
discover and innovate in science that
will save
people's lives and livelihood create
art write a book direct the movie
or play music that give hope and meaning
be a leader and build a community that
is diverse
resilient and kind thank you and
congratulations to you all
it is my privilege to request that peter
salovey conferred decree
degrees upon this year's graduates
mr president
i have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the graduate school
for the degree of master of advanced
study six
in number for the degree of master of
science
239 in number for the degree of master
of
arts 197 194
in number it's okay we didn't lose three
people
for the degree of master of philosophy
338
in number they have been recommended by
the faculty of the school
when they have been approved by the
corporation i will ask you by your
official act to confer upon them
these degrees by the authority vested in
me
i shall confer upon you the degrees in
the graduate school
as designated by the dean and shall then
admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Music]
by tradition the phd degree the highest
degree offered by universities
is conferred in latin at yale
prices clarissa may candidate
gratum philosophy doctors numero trace
kentum nonagente at sex tb presento
a
us
[Music]
yubeo salwere
et walerie
okay sorry i have to get my page again
thank you president salve
congratulations
to every one of you earning your degrees
during such difficult and challenging
times
the mission of the graduate school is to
train scholars to push the boundaries of
knowledge
this requires a certain comfort with
uncertainty
it's a key attribute of a successful
graduate student
it is learned when you tackle difficult
questions
with rigor and discipline but in the
last 14 months or so
you have shouldered the additional
burden of of bringing your work to
fruition
somehow in the midst of a pandemic
in addition to the more usual challenges
of being a graduate student you have
coped with situations we
never expected your own illness or that
of your family members
disruptions in your research and your
ability to conduct field work
the stress of doing absolutely
everything differently because of
evolving health and safety requirements
without knowing what would be thrown at
you next
and the compassionate awareness that
others are suffering in great numbers
all around us
from the dual weight of covet and
heightened awareness
of inequality and racism in our country
despite all of that despite what you
have been through you have persisted
with great courage
to pursue your research and uphold your
personal responsibilities
all the while embracing your duties as
good friends
neighbors and citizens you have found
like those who have gone before you that
graduate school is about negotiating the
frontier of what is known
and what is unknown not only in the
course of research but in life itself
i don't think we have a single word for
that liminal state
but we could describe it as a tolerance
for ambiguity
when you started graduate school several
years ago you
may remember my telling you that the
romantic
poet john keats called this state
negative capability or the capacity to
thrive
in the midst of uncertainty and doubt
keats and others after him understood
negative capability as a prerequisite
for discovery and creativity and
although it may be discomforting at
times
you have probably found that to be true
for yourself as well
to become the scholars and researchers
you are and aspire to be
you know you know you need to be
comfortable
even excited when faced with uncertainty
and mystery to push forward the
boundaries of what we know
and and know and understand about the
world
we have to be a bit unsettled by it
there are other powerful competencies
you you have
skills that are attractive to potential
employers
in addition to making you better a
better researcher and
an intrepid seeker of knowledge you
know how to tap into your innate
curiosity
and to confront complicated problems in
a systematic way
you can manage the twists and turns of
research
work with others who may hold different
perspectives from your own
and and communicate your ideas with
clarity
and grace you have the ability to
identify a problem or an issue and
pursue it
until a solution is found or knowledge
is gained
without being discouraged well mostly
without being discouraged
and your skills in problem solving
embracing differences
and building constructive friendships
will help you when faced with the
vicissitudes of work
and personal life anyone can have a
passion for an idea or a subject
but a graduate student learns how to
carry it forward with determination and
optimism
this is the very reason a graduate
degree matters
during a pandemic or any other time our
unwavering commitment to critical
inquiry
intellectual rigor and creative problem
solving
give us what we need to confront any
difficulty
address any unexpected development
and the world needs you right now
to apply what you have learned to the
most intractable questions and
predicaments of our time
i invited professor iwasaki to talk with
you today
not only because she's an inspiring
speaker
but because she's an example of someone
who uses her training to actively
solve a problem of great complexity even
as it unfolds
it is true that we are living through an
extraordinary time
but i wish to leave you with the good
news
that you are ideally prepared to face
today's challenges
and any that may arise in the future
you can work your way towards solutions
using the skills you have learned here
at yale
we confer your degrees upon you in all
confidence
looking forward to see what you will
accomplish
you leave yale as thinkers explorers
creators and teachers inventive
and original scholars leaders and
communicators
whatever direction you choose let your
accomplishments
inspire you to tackle new challenges
knowing
you have what it takes to confront the
unforeseen
it has been my privilege to lead the
graduate school's
efforts to provide you with the
environment that helped you grow into
the scholars
you are today i'm hugely proud of what
you have accomplished and excited to see
what you will do next
congratulations
and now to close our ceremony i'd like
to invite chaplain
sharon coogler for her parting words to
you and to benediction
at the end of her wonderful book
wintering
catherine may writes about the annual
gaelic festival
of imblok which takes place
in early spring this celebration
involves dusting away the cobwebs and
other remnants
of the long winter months and examines
what it takes to emerge
from a relentlessly tough season
a season reminiscent of graduate studies
with a global pandemic
superimposed over it intellectual
emotional and spiritual labor has been
the constant
with uncertainty dwelling in dark
corners
may writes about the unfurling of new
leaves
and learning to cope with the debris of
a long
disordered season she gives us this to
ponder
but we are brave and a new world awaits
us
gleaming and green
alive with the beat of wings
and besides we have a kind of gospel to
tell now
and a duty to share it we who have
wintered
have learned some things we sing it out
like birds
we let our voices fill the air
my beloved yale family you have learned
some things you have done it
and at times it has felt impossible but
you have crawled through
a long hard disordered season
now go forth with joy for you have made
it
you have a duty to share what you have
learned and to sing it out like birds
we take leave of this place filled with
gratitude for our families
friends teachers and guides
we are mindful of those we cherish who
are not here
and whose presence is sorely missed
today though
we are here we are alive
with the beat of wings on this day
and every day forward may all that is
holy
shine upon us and tenderly bless
our every breath may we go
in shalom in salam
in shanti may we go in peace
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
you